- Something we do have in common,
my mother and I actually
have in common as well,
we read a lot of books together,
and you love, you're
an avid reader as well.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- So, I mean, are you
currently reading anything cool
I should know about?
- Well, I'm reading "Caste."
It's kind of heavy,
so I have to just read
a little bit at a time.
You just can't sit there
and read the whole book.
But what are you reading?
- I just, well, I just
read your book actually,
but I also read I think
it's "The Dutch House?"
Ann Patchett?
- Oh yeah, I've read that!
Oh, you did?
- Oh,
- don't you love Ann Patchett?
- I love when you find an author you love
that really captivates you
and keeps you kind of
enthralled in the book.
- She did one of my book talks,
and I loved her so much that I invited her
to come to the vice president's
residence and she came!
And so that was so neat
to get to meet her,
and it's so nice when you
get to meet these people
who are, you know, your idols,
and as an English teacher,
of course, you know,
I love authors, so.
- Yeah!
- [Kelly] Yeah, that is nice perk.
- And she has her own
bookstore, you know that.
- Yes, yes, I did, I did.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I think that's gotta be
one of the coolest perks of this job.
You're like, hey, you want to come
swing by the White House and hang out?
(Kelly laughs)
(Jill laughs)
And then they do!
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's incredible.
- And actually it's funny,
that's why, I'm a singer
first and foremost,
but I, you know, I
signed up to do this job,
and I get to meet so
many incredible people.
So it's kind of a similar thing.
I get to interview so
many people that I idolize
and look up to and I'm inspired by.
So it's a really cool thing, I agree.